leute herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
folge ein tag persönlicher koch heute
ist die wirklich besonders
ich weiß nicht sagen dass oft aber heute
koche ich für meine mama die frau die 18
jahre lang mein persönlicher kopf kann
man ins bild das erste mal dass über und
youtube zu sehen
hallo morgen ja das bewegtbild du wirst
heute von ihm bekommt für so aufgeregt
ich bin total aufgeregt aber es ist für
mich ein ganz besonders schöner tag und
dass ich das erleben darf steht ich habe
diese leidenschaft auf jeden fall von
meiner mama geerbt deshalb muss ich mir
mühe geben ich würde sagen wir legen los
mit ihm früh starten relativ leicht in
den tagen wir haben auch schon fast 10
uhr beim frühstück immer nämlich welche
spät oder gar nicht dementsprechend gibt
es ein glas
ich weiß nicht ob wir das vielleicht
kennt das ist so ein klassisches hotel
ding dazu einfach ein bisschen
schnittlauch einzuwenden sagt rahn und
einen topf und trüffelöl also gibt's zu
trinken ein smoothie und ein frisches
dinge brötchen dass ich beim bäcker
geholt hat ich fange an habe ich es
vergessen hast du gesagt hast du ja auch
sagt gekauft haben einfach vergessen wo
ungefähr 230 millimeter sagt
ich sehe das noch kurzen schnellen topf
mit wasser auf in den topf reicht jetzt
richtig viel sagen ich wäre dann ja
gleich die eier kochen das seit ist für
den auftrieb der adam die nicht
irgendwie unten auf den boden kommen die
soll nämlich möglich den tag bleiben
ok dann mache ich hier mal weiter
sollten so 240 milliliter sein
da fällt es ihm respekt etwa so wächst
krankheit und damit irgendwas mixa macht
auf jeden fall immer zuerst die
flüssigkeit rein schützt nämlich die
messer und dazu kommt jetzt eine banane
ist selbst gar kein großer bananen fan
aber sind so in so einem milchshake das
ist so wirklich für mich eine der
wenigen situationen in denen ich bananen
tolerieren kann und dabei 200 gramm
erdbeeren und 50 ps mango sehr ehrenvoll
und dann können wir es eigentlich
anstellen sehr sehr leid so leer ist
nicht nur der topf sondern auch eine
schiefen weltkarte ich gebe jetzt einen
kleinen schuss weißem essig ins wasser
das trägt dazu bei dass wenn irgendwie
was aus dem ei herauskommen sollte man
bleibt drin bei asics drin
dann habe ich hier unsere eier die krieg
sich alma mich manchmal vier stücken und
jetzt bin ich hier vorsichtig die eier
direkt auf gedacht war reif für höhere
1961 abnehmen sodass dann habe ich ja
noch frischem schnittlauch und ich
schneide ich jetzt ganz so viel mehr
wollen wir dann streuen wir gleich ein
bisschen drüber
dazu dann wie gesagt noch sarah 12 fan
und trüffel ist schrecklich die eier ab
ihr könnt es leider nicht sehen aber
einfach das wasser drüber laufen lassen
und jetzt muss man ja ja einfach allen
hier ist das erste was mir jetzt ganz
vorsichtig ins nichts passieren ins glas
kurzen
die räume jetzt schon auf das wird jetzt
gegessen so leute da sitzen wir das
früheste es riecht wirklich sehr gut er
sagt man gibt auch so ein bisschen farbe
ab compair einschoss lasst uns gerne
probieren also ich noch mal stoff kommt
leise symbol hatte ich fühle mit guten 1
zucker drin oder überhaupt ganz
fantastisch dass das starke das wird ein
tag holt also eigentlich das mache ich
mir nie selber und das gibt es nur im
hotel
das ist einfach fantastisch merken
hinter uns auch ein bisschen im
hintergrund auch ein bisschen action wir
sehen uns gleich wieder wenn wir auch
gegessen haben zu bewerten so leute
aufgegessen und ihr selbst vielleicht
das glas mit meiner mama ist ein
bisschen gelb denn die eier habe ich auf
die herausnahmen das war deutlich besser
du hattest recht sechs minuten waren die
eier drin die waren acht minuten drin
also macht auf jeden fall eher in die
richtung vielleicht sogar fünf kommen
wir aber zu bewerten also das kam flotte
der die erklärt sie ist also die gesamte
komposition kriegt nur 8 von dir ja also
dass moody war umwerfend es ist nur
deshalb keine zehn geworden weil die
eintippen zu hart war ja klasse mit dem
brötchen isst was leichtes ich es ja
nicht so gern als privatmann führt so
als könnte man jetzt umgehen oder wenn
man es nicht so erschlagen ist jetzt
kein trend sehr gute 8 punkte zum
frühstück zum mittagessen werde ich mit
extrem jugend wir sehen uns da und wir
kommen zum mittagessen heute mittag gibt
es einen salat mit thunfisch steak das
ist sehr fancy sehr nice wir fahren alle
denen wir das tun für speck würfeln wir
warten das nämlich gleichen würfen an
und danach marinieren wie erst nein das
wie gesagt in würfel das geht übels
durch wuppertal ist durch krise was
nichts machen wir weiter mit unserer
marinade frauen-team war
damit sammelt man schon mal große
pluspunkte leider manchmal sobald
irgendwo irgendwo auftaucht dann
irgendwann mal ich jetzt ganz fein ist
jetzt hier sohn oscar treibe das muss
jedoch mit einer micro flächen oder so
hauptsache kein manchmal so 20
milliliter wasser hinzugefügt ein
teelöffel häuschen soße ein teelöffel
sojasauce
übrigens ein bisschen die mieten sagt
dazu klein wenig salz chronik so wenn
alles nicht ist kann ja auch schon die
thunfische wölfl reingeben und lassen
jetzt 23 minuten darin marinieren
wer das ganze ein bisschen variiert ist
neben es auch schon raus gehen jetzt den
rest mit der marinade ziehen eine kleine
schüssel
dazu kommt noch ein bisschen wasser und
zwei teelöffel brauner zucker
ich habe schon wieder das wirkt das
kochen was kommen wird kurz auf somit
unseren kunden erhalten wir jetzt weiter
in dem ich hier ein paar angetastet
weiße saison körner war normal weißen
lesen können verwischt so und sobald es
vermischt ist nehmen wir den thunfisch
und drehen von allen seiten einmal in
dem see sah dann so aus das ganze machen
wir mit allen vier würfel so sehen die
thunfisch würfe aus wenn sie ummantelt
sind
das ist irgendwie ein bisschen japanisch
auch ja unsere marinade mit dem zucker
ist jetzt hier einmal hochgekocht so
dass ganze servieren wir auf einen
rucola-salat das heißt den wasche ich
mal kurz
[Musik]
da könnte es auch schon mal an das
dressing vom salat machen wir brauchen
wie olivenöl und olivenöl ein bisschen
weißem essig zitronensaft also in sagt
von 34 zitrone dann einheit esslöffel
sesamöl das greift schön die kruste auf
die wir um den tisch herum haben fast
das ganze zusammen überraschen ich mir
wollen ist es wieder passiert die
kameras ausgang ich habe keine ahnung
was du nicht drauf waren hier habe ich
auf jeden fall unsere marinade am anfang
am anfang noch auf dem herd stehen hier
als die pfanne vorhin der wir gleich den
thunfisch anbraten werden aber ganz
wichtig nur pro seite 20 30 sekunden in
der mitte bleibt dagegen noch
soßenbinder zu kollegen in die pfanne
und gebe ich hier schon mal was vom
dressing zu unserem salat die pure
ischgl schlecker und die fahrer heute
motive ist jetzt auf temperatur und da
geben wir jetzt unsere thunfischsteaks
rein wie gesagt 20 sekunden pro seite
jede seite strikt 20 sekunden
ich bin mit dem ich ein bisschen große
mengen toter wird per 1
und wie gesagt jetzt hier alle seiten
bis auf vorne und hinten zweimal sogar
schon gedreht das heißt schon bei der
letzten seite ihr seht dass ihr
vielleicht schon auseinander
jetzt mache ich noch ein paar frische
chili in unseren gästen ein dass das
ganze noch schärfer
dazu bekommt oh ja richtig gewesen und
dann kommt auch schon aus hitze weg
schnapp mir dass zwei tiefe täler
jetzt können wir auch schon 54 61
zentimeter dicke scheiben
sie legen wir jetzt über den salat
drüber und der salat kriegt jetzt zum
abschluss noch ein bisschen von dem
tresor oben drüber
[Musik]
da setzen wir das mittagessen das ist
dir schmecken roh war ich vorher nicht
so einfach mal im thunfisch probieren
hier kann man wirklich kommt immer
gerade so auseinander ziehen kann mich
nicht erinnern dass ich gut so ein fisch
gegessen
das ist was wirklich ne mittel mit dem
grace und drüber der auf diese schärfe
mitspringen kann ich mir gedacht dass
das ist das wirklich das ist fantastisch
also da hab ich schon loslegen ich kann
es kaum erwarten also ich sitze hier und
strahlte wie ein honigkuchenpferd weil
ich bin zwar die mama von max aber ich
wusste nicht dass er so eine kanone ist
ich habe hier gerade was gegessen das
hätte aus meiner feder kommen können und
ich koche schon seit 59 jahren für mich
ist das bombastische also ich bin
begeistert ich finde es macht kurs mama
hat auch zwischendurch ein glas wein
rausgerückt um darauf anzustoßen ich
habe auch schulterklopfer bekommen und
alles also ich glaub ich bin total stolz
auf meinen sohn und ich habe eine
vermutung was das heißen könnte von 0
bis 10
ja was ist es gibt auch ausnahmsweise
mehr als zehn ja ich kann zu machen
ich würde sagen 15 15 wirklich der
gipfel könnte alles klar
das war waren sind kannst du genauso
bestätigen man fühlt sich einfach gut
danach wenn wir uns gegessen hat auch so
leicht auch nach dem frühstück durch so
trägt also durch den tag
aber das abendessen sollte dadurch
nochmal alles geben wir sehen uns da ist
wieder da und rinderfilet geben mit
rotwein zwiebeln und ofenkartoffeln
fahren dem wir die roten zwiebeln
erstmal halbieren und dann der länge
nach schneiden
ihr habt gerade den sprung gesehen ich
kann es wirklich selbst nicht glauben
diese dumme kamera die ich für 4000 euro
gekauft habe ich kann sie einfach
anscheinend nicht vernünftig bedient auf
jeden fall fehlt mir eine ganze stunde
in der stunde habe ich unter anderem
einfach die zwiebeln fertig geschnitten
in einem topf 750 liter rotwein 125
milliliter portwein und drei esslöffel
balsamico-essig aufgesetzt als gekocht
hat habe ich die zwiebeln hinzugefügt
dann habe ich acht möhren geschält und
die zusammen mit einem stängel
zitronengras zwei esslöffel braunem
zucker sternanis und einem esslöffel
butter in den backofen getan in alufolie
gewickelt da noch wasser aufgesetzt
kartoffeln geschält und die kartoffeln
ins wasser gegeben für kartoffelpüree
die rotwein zwiebeln sind schon ganz gut
reduziert die kartoffeln sind auch
einfacher auch schon unsere rotwein
zwiebeln nehmen und abschnitten durch
die fahrer jetzt gegen ihn nur die
zwiebeln zurück in den tag gehen
erstmals zwei esslöffel braunen zucker
hinzufügen wenn wir das ganze mal jetzt
herunter hier können sie auch schon
wieder drauf geben
diese von playa schuss grob fahrlässig
so die lassen wir jetzt vor sich hin
köchelt erreicht werden das stellen wir
weiter an die seite der rest kommt rein
es können ja auch schon hier unsere
dreifacher aufsetzen und da wirklich
orten also stufe 9 und großes feld der
zwischenzeit sollen auch schon unsere
und fertig sein ich gucke mittlerweile
schon mal drei minuten auf die kamera
doch alles nicht mehr die kraft sich
nicht richtig schon sehr gut und stellt
er einfach an die seite können
tatsächlich noch länger ein
dann kümmern wir uns hier drüben
erreicht auf unsere stakes wir trennen
die selber haut ab so leute und wer die
ganze selber habe ist können wir schon
linie wenn die pfanne geben
dann geben wir ein wenig fett hier in
die pfanne war es geht direkt ab jetzt
komplett weg und da drei minuten pro
seite
das war vielleicht ein bisschen zu
halten
machen wir hier die erste seite auf dem
ist sechs band ist jetzt halt wirklich
zu casten
es musste jetzt gar nicht rein ich muss
irgendwie muss hier ein bisschen
abnehmen besser erlebt leute kenne das
nur so dass man büchen maximale hitze
macht aber das habe ich zu halten weiß
dass abzutrennen was hier halt zu krass
ist und dann gibt es da mal rein
also die kruste ist auf jeden fall da
ist auch hier wird aber an manchen
stellen uns natürlich gefreut doch
anscheinend lieber mein haupt ich würde
jetzt noch mal die karotten lauch
kartoffeln haben ist er richtig küchen
chaos hier leute
alter schwede hoffe dass das fleisch
noch okay ist weil es hat ein übels die
bitterstoffe entwickelt an den stellen
wo es zu schwarz geworden ist karotten
sollen ich erstmal weiter ziehen dann
machen wir vorne weiter großer esslöffel
butter zu den kartoffeln dann ordentlich
milch und trüffelöl am rhein noch frisch
muskatnuss kann
[Musik]
dafür auf jeden fall das stressigste
essen
ihr habt gesehen was da abging weil du
kommst in aller seelenruhe auf der couch
stellen würde sagen wir probieren das
ganze mal gemeinsam cameron
dort muss mir also ich finde arbeitet
sich langsam vor ich fange an sein
produkt ist okay okay ich mache genau
das gleiche mit superkräften klatscht
rheine
so kann es weiter gehen und diese
märchen haben mich ja sehr sehr antritt
ist interessiert nach dem rezept das ist
ja der hammer hindurch serie gehört ich
habe angst dass fleisch fleisch so schon
gar punkt und anschnitt super so schön
medium ja und der geschmack superzahl
natürlich weiß darum bei dem bei dem
stück das ich jetzt gerade hatte sind
keine bitterstoffe durchbekommen ich
habe neulich bleibt von dem was ich
abgetrennt haben aktiviert und das hätte
man nicht essen können also mein fleisch
war tadellos der leute ich habe mir dann
ist die existenzkrise
wir essen auf und dann kommen jetzt die
bewertung der teller ist leer
ja sehr spannend heute abend du hast ein
wunderbares trüffel püree mir zubereitet
die möhren mit ingwer und zitronengras
waren der kraftkur bei dem steak muss
ich sagen deine deine zuschauer haben es
mitbekommt die fahne war zu heiß du hast
die situation professionell gedruckt du
hast das fleisch herausgeholt hast das
was nicht gut gegangen ist bestmöglich
gelöst und hast uns hier auf dem teller
ein fleisch hin serviert das butterzart
war von verbrennung war nichts zu
schmecken
läuft diese wunderbaren rotwein zwiebeln
waren ein gedicht ich habe nachts nach
genommen davon einziger kritikpunkt die
rotweinsauce aber ich muss auch sagen
ich bin sehr positiv überrascht gewesen
von comstage weil ich hier gesehen habe
mühsam abgetan ich gar nicht gesehen du
nicht dann habe ich es nochmal an
gerüstet ich war sehr kritisch selbst
aber es war wie weg also kompliment will
kompliment aber nur zehn ist es nicht
wegen dieser situation ich gebe daher 99
auch schon wieder 15 heute nachmittag
heute abend also waren sie noch neun zum
abendessen leute ich bin wirklich ganz
freiwillig das gerettet habe aber
insgesamt haben wir haben wir die neuen
besco ich weiß nicht aber das nehmen
danke fürs dabei sein aber es war mir
eine große ehre es war sehr aufregend
heute und für mich war ist ein abenteuer
und ich bin total happy end zu erfahren
dass mein sohn irgendwie ohne dass ich
wusste voll in meine fußstapfen nächste
woche leute wird es genauso
anspruchsvoll ihr werdet sehen warum bis
dahin sonntag pizzen oder macht's gut
[Musik]